I've met people that say you know I need
more money I'm like why do you need more
money they're like well I need more
money so that I can retire a little
earlier why do you want to retire
earlier well I want to spend more time
with my kids well if you want to spend
more time with them what if you could
spend it now oh I can't spend it now
because I have this job it's like well
the thing you really want might be to
find a way to work a job that has more
flexibility and maybe you don't actually
care about retiring 5 years early maybe
you actually care about having
flexibility now but we started this
whole conversation about you wanting
more money in product management there's
this thing called the five WI where a
customer says oh I want this thing and
you're like why and they're like well
this and you're like why and you just
keep asking why until you get to the
point like oh that's what your your
unmet need really is yeah and I think we
don't do we we might do this as product
managers doing research but we don't do
it with ourselves so you're asking why
do you want this thing dig dig dig
deeper to figure out if maybe the thing
that you actually wanted is something
completely different and that allows you
to change your
perspective